there is growing concern that the corona
virus may spread farther than previously
thought in those tiny airborne particles
we keep hearing about it's commonly
understood that those particles for
example from a sneeze can spread up to
six feet without a mask but more than
200 scientists are now urging the w-h-o
to reconsider their guidance on that
when it comes to indoor spaces our chief
medical correspondent dr. Jon LaPook
spoke with two of the scientist
researchers around the world say the
evidence is clear the corona virus is
likely airborne when we call for sneeze
larger airborne droplets containing
virus can travel usually up to about six
feet but smaller particles can be
emitted simply by talking or singing and
can go much farther and linger in the
air for hours they don't fall to the
ground in six feet and they can remain
in the air for hours and potentially
infectious for hours what would you like
the w-h-o to do acknowledge that the
risk goes beyond six feet dr. Don Milton
co-wrote the letter signed by nearly 240
scientists from around the world how
certain are you that aerosols are
playing a significant role in the
transmission of copán 19 pass a six to
eight feet you look at the restaurantt
outbreak in Grand rows several bus
outbreaks in China and it's clear that
one person could infect people over much
more than six feet in some circumstances
those aerosols can travel more than 30
feet each layer of protection helps like
this cloth mask that partially blocks an
aerosol from a simulated cough what
implication does that have for somebody
in their home or in their office indoors
you need to have everybody wearing masks
who are not in the same bubble and that
you need to have good ventilation
improve ventilation systems are a top
priority for New York's Governor Andrew
Cuomo if there is a way to filter the
air and there's a way to get kovat out
of the air then we want to do that dr.
Jon LaPook joins us now John we're so
hung up on six feet six feet six feet
and now I just heard you say the
particles can go 30 feet does that mean
if somebody's 30 feet
for me that I can get it from 30 feet
out now potentially I mean the
aerosolization process itself with the
tiny you know 5 micron particles
floating out drying out it's rough on
the virus but we have seen instances
where it looks like that happens for
example in super spreader events
remember the choir in Washington state
where one person looks like they
inspected 52 others and it doesn't look
like it could have been totally on the
basis of just droplet you know within 6
to 8 feet yes I also heard the
scientists say it doesn't just state
drop to the ground that it could linger
in the air so John how are we supposed
to move in the world what are we
supposed to do I think you know the
scientists I spoke to like Kim Prather
who you heard said you know don't be
afraid of this this is an opportunity
now that we know that there's an issue
we can try to fix it so for example in
buildings we need to make them healthier
we need to improve the ventilation maybe
we put filters in the in the air maybe
we put UV filters that can destroy the
virus in the ducts it shouldn't be scary
to people open the window crack the door
simple things but once we know that
there's a problem we have some of the
greatest engineers on the planet in the
United States now we know there's an
issue let's deal with it and start with
the basics wear your masks wear your
masks
thank you dr. Jon LaPook we're always
good to see you